AND HE TAKES A SHOT.
IT'S A SAFE, THEY WILL PUT IT
BACK UP TOP.
HE
AND STOPS ONCE.
HE'S THE PLAYER WHO SCOOPS IT  .
NOW HE'S HELD UP ALONG HE SCORE
NECK, HE'S THE MOST VETERAN OF
THE GUYS AND HE'S NONGS ARE
UP 3-0.
ANYTHING TO DENY THE PASS
COMING ACROSS THE MIDDLE.
HE'S IN THE MIDDLE, THAT PUCKS
HE'S LJOHANSEN,
BACKHANDED CHOP AND  WINS THE G
HE WILL SEND IT AROUND, .
>> Ray: WHAT A GREAT CHANCE SI
OF THE CROSS, A SHOT.
>> Ray: IS THE COMPETITORS
GETTING UP IN THE PLAY.
ROMAN JOSI  EIR OWN
END.
REBO
FIRE THE PUCK FROM THE OUTSIDE
AND ON THE MOVE. JOSI  GOT INTO
THE RUSH,
HE LOSES THE HANDLE AND HERE
COMES KEMPE.
TAKES THE SHOT, RITTICH  CONNEC.
L.A.
HAS ED IT UP INTO THE
NETTING.
HE SENT THE BELOW THE GOAL AND
IT'S RIGHT IN FRONT.
HE
KEMPE   KUPARI.
USING HIS LEGS, HE FORCES
IS FACED WITH THAT THE ROOKIES
ARE DOING WONDERS IN ATLANTA.
RIGHT IN FRONT, TO
NOT ONCE, NOT TWICE BUT QUICK
IN THE SECOND PERIOD